[Music]
hi
my name is riva and i'm a linguist who
uses r seven years ago i tried to learn
r
and i failed i wasn't sure where to
start my art journey so as someone with
a background in the humanities
i thought the best option was reading a
book
i wanted to make one of those cool plots
with a great background i've seen around
to communicate some results
so i picked a book that promised me that
i will learn the most important elements
of art
on page 99 i was still reading about
defining classes and methods
trying to understand what an array was
and how to multiply its elements
but hadn't done anything with real data
yet
the problem i think were my expectations
i was expecting learning resources that
helped me say things with data
but all i found were description of
rules that didn't make much sense to me
as a beginner
it was very difficult for me to see how
i can use these rules with the data i
had
and how i will jump from these abstract
descriptions to
for example making a plot it felt like
trying to learn a second language
only by reading a grammar book and not
by interacting with actual human beings
the thing is that learning a programming
language has many similarities with
learning a second language
but what does this mean how can this
idea be applied to the design of
learning resources
or when choosing them to guide your
learning path and how can you take this
into account when developing a package
for example
first let's take a let's talk about
learning
not everyone learns a second language
with the same purposes
the same happened with programming
languages i failed learning r the first
time
because i wasn't expected audience for
the book i chose
at the moment i just wanted to be an art
user not a programmer
not everyone is learning art to be a
linguist or a grammarian of the language
there are surely people that want a deep
understanding of how the language works
and those are the people who are
contributing to its development
but there are tons of people that just
want to use r to do things
like making a plot or running a
statistical model or creating reports
i feel the first time i tried to learn
art because the book i chose for
learning was the equivalent of a grammar
book of art
descriptions of how the language works
and the names and purposes of all its
different parts
and as a beginner or someone who just
want to learn the language to
communicate your data to others
that is not what is more useful what you
need is something that works more
like a textbook textbooks for learning a
second language
always start the same you learn how to
say hello
how to introduce yourself and some
simple sentences to communicate meaning
to others
even books for learning dead languages
have this approach
i had to learn a little bit of latin as
an undergrad and the first thing we
learned was how to
ask someone who they are and how to
respond to that question
i even learned how to insult someone in
latin
a language in which the last native
speakers speaker died
centuries ago textbooks start this way
because they are built around people's
needs and knowledge not our own language
rules
in textbooks you learn first what you
can do with a language
not how the language how the language
works
in language teaching this is called a
communicative approach
and it's based on the idea that learning
a language successfully
comes from having to communicate real
meaning to real people
throughout the different lessons in your
textbook you learn new words and
structures
and new contexts for you to use those
words and structures
the grammar rules behind those real life
examples are only explained
after you learn how to use them and if
an old if
is really necessary for you to know them
in textbooks
scaffolding works as a spiral you learn
something in one lesson
and then come back to that content in
the next lesson but now showing more
ways to use
what you learn how to adapt it to
different situations
and how to combine the words and
structures you know
in new ways it's like copy and pasting
and then adapting you learn how to use a
new language structure
like how to ask a question and then you
learn how to adapt it to your own needs
to solve the problems you're interested
in
is this ability to adapt language
structures to new situations
what makes us flexible users in both
natural languages and programming ones
for example we first learn how to create
one type of plot using all the default
settings
and then we come back to that content to
add more complexity to the visualization
like mapping more variables using
different gems or making annotations
and we build those new skills over the
ones we learned previously
this copy-pasting and adapting is also a
strategy we use with examples we find in
stack overflow
or our studio community we bring to our
scripts something that work
in another context and then try to
figure out how to adapt it to our own
needs
sometimes we are not even sure why it
worked but after doing it a couple of
times we start inferring what is going
on behind the scenes
you don't need to know all the grammar
rules to be understood in language and
you don't need to know the name of all
its structures to be a competent users
even native speakers don't know the name
of all the parts
you probably don't know what a
paratactic or a hypotactic clause
complex complexes but you definitely
know how to use one
if you're a native english speaker you
know how to correctly pronounce every
case of two o's together
in words like moon book floor flood
something very very difficult for us not
native speakers
but you probably don't know why they are
pronounced differently
the adults who raised you didn't read
your grammar book for you to acquire
your native language
they didn't teach you the grammar rules
they talk to you and let you talk they
probably read your books
you sung or sign together you did things
with words progressively more complex
in the same way you don't need to know
all the rules of a programming language
to be able to do things with it what
rules do you need
the ones that can help you achieve the
purposes you're seeking
if you need to customize a plot in a
very precise way because the default
options are not what you need
then learning how a theme works in
ggblot is relevant
not before if you need to work with
arrays
then learning what they are and what
kind of things you can do with them
is relevant not before one more thing
about textbooks
they usually have learner personas if
you're learning a language
because you want to travel the first
chapters will probably show you
how to get along in the airport and ask
for directions in a city
if you're learning the language because
you're going to study abroad
the first chapters will probably be
about students trying to find something
in the campus or dealing with university
bureaucracy
the same happens with programming
learning resources
fortunately in the past couple of years
a lot of online resources have appeared
to learn our and other programming
languages
and many of them are focused on the
needs of specific users
so all the data and examples are
connected with what those specific users
need and know so taking into account the
community
approach when teaching programming
language involves
doing real things from day or page one
building complexity as a spiral
revealing rules after you know how
and when to use them and all the ones
that can help you achieve
what you're looking for and taking into
account
who your learner personas are in the
last couple of years
a lot of our resources have been created
taking into account these principles
learning resources that let you
experiment first and then
build explanations books that show you
the whole game first
and then explain the details behind
every step
publication that having my different
learner personas with different
backgrounds
that show you how to do relevant things
with relevant data
for your field but hey what about the
other books the ones that explain how r
works
well those actually are very cool books
i'm a linguist myself so i really love
grammar books
but for both natural and programming
languages they are not the first step to
approach a language
when what you want is to learn how to
use it and how to communicate with other
people but is this communicative
approach
only relevant for people teaching or
learning r
what about programmers what about people
developing packages
well thinking package development from a
communicative point of view can also
help us in issues like developing more
useful error messages and documentation
let's take a look at error messages
first whatever you're learning having
feedback is the kind of thing that can
help you improve
this applies to inhuman activity from
sports to cooking from knitting to
language learning having this in mind
let's take a look at two error
messages addressing the same problem we
all have been here
putting one instead of two equal signs
to filter a column
this is the error message to getting
base r it says error unexpected equal
sign in
and then the part of the code where the
equal ex when the unexpected evil sign
is
here message here is pointing you where
your mistake is
but there is no clue on how to solve it
why is the equal sign
unexpected should i put something else
and if you you're not an english speaker
there is even more enigmatic
pointing errors is not the same as
giving feedback
to learn from your mistakes you not only
need to know
where the order is but you need some
clues on how to solve it
so next time you know what to do let's
take a look at the method
for the same error but using the filter
function from dply
your message says error problem with
filter
input 1. input one is name
this usually means that you have used
one equal sign instead of two
did you mean country to equal signs
chile
run r long last error to see where they
are occurring
this message let us know what the
problem is
its probable origin a suggestion how it
can be solved
and if and only if you want to know
where your code fail
how to take a detailed look
what we have here is feedback we not
only learn the origin of the problem and
how to solve it
but also how we can take a deeper look
at the code to see where the error
occurred
and if you're not an english speaker you
can put this on google translate and
we'll get something useful
this couple of extra lines in your
function code can make
a lot of people it can make the life of
many people easier
and help them fail in a way they can
learn
giving useful feedback is the best way
to learn how to overcome
difficulties and this is something we do
all the time when someone is learning
our native language
if you don't understand what they are
trying to communicate you
you usually say things like sorry did
you mean
and try to rephrase what they said to
check if you understand correctly their
intention
we don't go around saying people lack of
subject verb agreement
or misplace modifiers we don't
do that because it is not really helpful
for learners
it's more effective to give cues on how
to fix the problem
and show how a correct version might
look like
so if you're a package developer and
want people to be happy users with your
package
you can think about how your error
messages can give guidance
but error messages are not the only part
of a package that can adopt a
communicative approach
let's take a look at documentation
function documentation
is great sometimes you forget the name
of an argument and taking the help page
can allow you to solve this kind of
issue
but to use it you need to know the
actual name of the function you're after
otherwise it's kind of useless what if
you
know the problem you want to solve but
not the name of the function that can
help you solve it
function documentation are like
dictionaries
they have the definition of the words
you can use in a programming language
but we don't learn a language but
memorizing words from the dictionary
we need to learn how to use the words in
what context they are useful
what kind of meaning can they can we
construct with them
what if you don't know the name of the
function you need
what if you know what you want to
achieve but not what functions can be
useful for that
well here comes vignettes vignettes and
are awesome resources
to describe the problem that your
package is designed to solve
and to show people how to solve it they
are a great resource to show how to do
things
with your package with real example
and they are easy to find using a search
engine so they are
also a great way to promote your package
in a vignette you can explain with
details the different categories your
functions are divided
how you can coordinate multiple
functions to solve problems
and show extended examples that people
can copy paste and adapt to meet their
own needs
the best part is that vignettes are easy
to create
using the uses package with uses use
vignettes you can create one
so thinking of error messages as a way
to give feedback to the users of your
package
and writing vignettes that explain how
to do things with the functions you
create
are great ways to think about package
development from a communicative
approach
two closing remarks is really are the
best
programming language to learn isn't
python better
or what about julia with programming
languages happens the same
as with natural languages there is no
one intrinsically better than the other
the best programming language is the one
that can help you solve more effectively
the problem you are trying to solve
in the context you currently are
sometimes
things like processing time or number of
lines of code are important to take into
account
but sometimes they are not and only what
is easier or faster for you to write
not the computer to process is more
important
and sometimes is more relevant what
programming language your audience can
understand
the same happens with natural languages
right now
i would really prefer to be speaking
spanish but it's definitely more
effective if i speak in english
not because of any characteristic of
english language itself
actually for this subject in particular
spanish is way more precise
because we have more words to speak
about language we make distinctions like
language all of which have
different and precise meanings so i need
to use more words in english to explain
those concepts
but right now being able to convey my
message to a broader audience is more
important
than lexical variety or precision that
spanish offers to the subject
so which programming language to learn
the one that can help you best solve the
problems you're interested in
and that allow you to speak with the
people you're interested
in communicating with at that moment and
with
and with another language knowing and
the same way as with natural languages
knowing
more than one allow you to communicate
with more people and do more things with
words
and this leads us to the second closing
remark
communication and community and
community has the same etymology
a communicative approach in programming
languages is important because it can
help us build stronger communities
where everyone can be part of the
conversation new people learning the
language
can offer new and diverse perspective
and we should cherish that
there is no one correct way to learn a
programming language
but there are many things that we can
that can be done to take
to make it more effective and enjoyable
failing to offer people opportunities to
learn in an easier way
or thinking that the only way to learn a
programming language is
the hard way is not only kind of a
gatekeeping issue
but it's also dangerous because the most
dangerous thing that can happen to a
natural or a programming language
is not having a vibrant community of
users to keep it alive
and evolving
[Music]
you